hello everybody we've got a ton of stuff
to talk about today am I live oh I am
live ok good
let's get a couple things ready here
because there are just so many things to
discuss you know we've only got a few
live streams left in the year 2019 and
of course if there are important
congressional hearings or other hearings
we will have them live I don't know what
else is scheduled right now but we as
far as just random streams we only have
a few left because Friday night I'm
going on vacation and we will be back
for a couple more shows right at the
very end of the year the 30th and the
31st but this week is basically it so I
will make every effort to be be here and
in fact we may even add a challenge
I actually was set up for it let me see
here yeah here it is let's see if I can
dream let me see the right way to get
this set up does that right there we go
so yeah we've got our if we get 50 new
members today we will open up the phone
lines and if we get 30 new members I
will commit to another stream this week
which will be certainly one of the last
of the year so I have so many things to
talk about it turns out that there's
this story Trump keeps telling about his
Jewish friend and he's told that four
different ways and it seems like it's
just a lie I don't think that'll shock a
lot of people there's a new poll that
shows Donald Trump doing very well in
Iowa but is it really well enough to
tell us what's going to happen in
November I would argue no we're going to
talk about that Donald Trump lost it on
Twitter today we're going to talk about
that we have some hilarious video of
Brian Kilmeade from Fox and Friends
saying he's stunned by polling that
shows half the country wants Donald
Trump impeached and removed we have Rudy
Giuliani saying the quiet part out loud
admitting to Adam antis that yeah he
wanted Murray Jovanovic out of the way
and then we also have some really funny
new video from Donald Trump ranting I
don't know what he's saying and we're
gonna see if you guys can help me figure
out what it is that
that that he meant to say so if you are
watching on YouTube remember that super
chats are the way to get questions or
comments to me they will pop up on the
screen and then I will read them and
then I will answer them and it's just an
amazing and beautiful thing we are also
live on Twitch and you can send me
messages with your twitch Prime
subscriptions that will also get me to
thank you
Jurgen Mann has subscribed with twitch
Prime which I appreciate and also tan
man six eight eight nine has subscribed
for the fifth month fifth month in a row
on Twitch Prime thank you so very much
so let's get right into it okay this is
Donald Trump Trump keeps telling the
same story about his Jewish friend
that's just delighted with what he's
done in Israel but every single time
it's a different friend sometimes it's
the people sometimes it's the owner of
the Patriots Robert Kraft sometimes it's
Jared Kushner's dad this is just
hilarious let's take a look at the video
[Music]
[Music]
that's September 9th what do you think
was bigger Israel and the embassy go
again
and it became Jerusalem the capital of
Israel or the Golan Heights he said
neither he said the biggest thing you
did for Israel was breaking up and
terminating the horrible one-sided
catastrophic deal that was made by
President Obama so the first time he
told the story on September 9 that was
people are telling him then on December
7th it was Sheldon Adelson a particular
Jewish person then four days later he
tells the story two more times and it's
two different people that told him this
which is bigger which is more important
to the Jewish people that said neither I
said what does that mean he said what
you did by terminating the Iran nuclear
deal is bigger than both I think so now
it was the Patriots owner who is telling
Trump this then I asked Charlie Kushner
I said Charlie let me ask you what's
bigger for the Jewish people
giving the embassy to Jerusalem right
open it silence I said what does that
mean he said the biggest thing of all is
what you did by ending the Iran nuclear
catastrophe so it's funny because every
single time it's a different person that
told him this I guess everybody is
completely on the same page or maybe the
story is fake and it's not it's not a
real thing I see people asking me about
the Genk youghurt interview or as
Brianna Keilar on CNN called him I think
she said chanc Weger the interview has
been recorded the interview was already
available to our paid members at join
pakman.com and the interview will be
published later tonight publicly but it
is already available
if you are a paid member and you can
sign up at join pakman.com you can see
the Genk interview it was scheduled to
be 15 minutes it went nearly a half hour
it is compelling we talked about the
smears against jank we talked about his
prior blog posts and I encourage you to
check it out if you sign up at join
pakman.com you can see it now otherwise
it'll be published close to midnight
Eastern Time today okay that's number
one
let's go on to our next story oh and let
me actually do some super chats
Sam Dean says via super chat Trump says
he wants to skip the debates maybe he
can maybe he can't I'm interested in
your opinion as to why he would want to
avoid the debates you know I haven't
seen that yet Sam so I would not be able
to comment because I'm not um I just
haven't seen Trump say he was skipping
the debates yet oh and see what it is
all about a thanks to Gator arrow for
subscribing with twitch prime over on
twitch I very much appreciate that okay
new polling that is very very important
out of Iowa let me get to the key part
that I want to discuss today where is it
here it is the Trump part that I want to
find um let's see if I can find it ah
here we go okay
so in this new poll out of Iowa
President Trump is leading his potential
Democratic opponents so there's we
really need context to understand this
so there's been a bunch of national
polls that came out which say oh my
goodness
Trump is getting crushed nationally in
hypothetical matchups in Trump versus
Biden Biden's winning by nine in Trump
vs. Bernie Bernie's winning by I think
it was seven Trump versus Warren
Warren's winning by eight is so on and
so forth and what it's important what is
important to understand about those
polls is that number one they have a lot
of undecideds in them so like Trump's
beating Biden 52:41 that's only ninety
one percent that leaves nine that are
either undecided or with a third party
whatever and eventually they may come
over to trump so Trump losing
to Biden 52 49 52 41 rather might be
Biden beating Trump nationally 52 47 and
that might be enough for an electoral
college victory for Donald Trump it was
against Hillary Clinton he lost to
Hillary by about three percentage points
in the popular vote so we really
shouldn't pay too much attention to
those polls in addition because usually
race has come down to the results in
some key states can the Democrat win
Wisconsin Pennsylvania Ohio North
Carolina I think you guys understand
that so this is a poll that purports to
be more relevant in the sense that it is
in Iowa and in Iowa President Trump
leads all potential Democratic opponents
in head-to-head matchups in Iowa the
president leads Budaj edge by 40 by one
point
46 to 45 against Biden he leads 49 to 45
against Sanders and Warren he leads
fifty two forty three so now we're on
the other side now we're saying we'll
hold on a second it looks like Trump
actually is going to crush it in 2020
because he's winning in Iowa but this is
not a full enough analysis you have to
go back and say wait a second what
happened in Iowa in 2016 in 2016
Trump won Iowa by 9 to 10 points over
Hillary it was like 51 41 or you know
fifty one to forty one and a half
something like that so in reality yes we
should be looking at state polling
because national polling doesn't
actually tell us who's gonna win the
electoral college but Trump winning in
Iowa by one four or seven is actually
worse than Donald Trump did in Iowa in
2016 so the correct analysis is we
should be looking at the state level but
it looks right now like Trump is doing
worse in Iowa than he did in 2016 which
may not bode well for him that's the the
analysis we need to do now all you'll
see on corporate media is Trump crushing
Dems in popular vote nationally okay
or I'm sorry Trump being crushed by Dems
nationally or from crushing Dems in Iowa
these are not full analyses you really
need to look
what happened in 2016 and for people in
in both YouTube and twitch chat saying
Trump is going to win re-election I'm
with you
I believe that the that the most likely
outcome is Donald Trump is reelected and
I am being upfront with my audience
about that and there's a number of
different reasons why I think that is
and that's not for our analysis today
but nobody's gonna prove me wrong if
Donald Trump gets reelected that nothing
has caught he's it's been Teflon Don
impeachment he's going to get acquitted
and my sense is that the most likely
scenario is he gets reelected that
doesn't mean I'm not gonna work to make
it something difficult something
different a super chat over on YouTube
from dat cookie who says if Trump is
impeached regardless of what happens in
the Senate he shouldn't be allowed to
run for president again period that's
know I mean I disagree with you if you
are that's like saying if you are
accused of a crime regardless of whether
you're found guilty or acquitted you
shouldn't be able to do X Y or Z that is
antithetical to the system we have so I
just simply don't agree if you have if
you can change my mind by all means go
ahead and change my mind but that's not
the way I see it okay let's go on to our
next story and okay so I see a lot of
people saying David are you opening the
phones I may open the phones we have
zero new members right now we have zero
of 15 new members to open the phones we
have our blowout last membership special
of the year the coupon code is last 2019
if folks start signing up then indeed we
we may open the phones but the phones
are not open right now I see that there
are people calling in there are probably
some really funny voicemails coming in
including from this conspiracy theorist
who goes by the name total control 871
and I'll get to some of those a little
bit later but I have a lot of things to
discuss with you first
okay there is a new report that is from
the House Judiciary Committee and it
asserts that Donald Trump actually did
commit crimes now one of the stories
that Republicans have been telling
around impeachment is how are you going
to impeach a president that didn't
commit a crime
well the
first answer to that is that there has
been no there is no reason that you need
a crime in order to impeach it's not a
criminal proceeding it's a political
proceeding but the House Judiciary
Committee report now does allege that
crimes were committed by Donald Trump so
anyway Trump went absolutely crazy today
starting again with read the transcripts
the impeachment hoax is the greatest con
job in the history of American politics
the fake news media and their partner
the Democrat Party are working overtime
to make life for the United Republican
Party al and all it stands for as
difficult as possible talks about his
approval rating once again he talks
about I look very much forward to
debating whoever the lucky person is who
stumbles across the cross the finish
line in the little watch do nothing
Democrat debates my record is so good on
the economy and all else including
debating that perhaps I would consider
more than three debates the problem is
that the so-called Commission on debates
is stacked with Trump haters and never
Trump errs three years ago they were
forced to publicly apologize for
modulating my microphone in the first
debate against crooked Hillary as
president the debates are up to me oh so
this is what that question was from Sam
and there are many options including
doing them directly and avoiding the
nasty politics of this very biased
Commission I will make a decision at an
appropriate time but in the meantime the
Commission on Presidential Debates
is not authorized to speak for me or
Republicans okay so there is what Sam
was talking about listen I to be
perfectly frank I think if Trump decides
not to do the debates it's unlikely to
hurt him that much because sure it's
gonna hurt him with people that already
aren't voting for him but I I'm telling
you this guy can get away with almost
everything and I think if he decides not
to do the debates it will be not
necessarily to his advantage but it will
end up being a non-factor in the sense
that he this isn't Nixon in the 70s it's
not the President does something
ridiculous and suffers the consequences
it's the president does something
ridiculous and then an entire for-profit
media apparatus that is sick of Fanta
canned brown-nosing will defend Trump
and create counter narratives so I would
not be surprised if skipping the debates
does nothing
hurt Donald Trump let me say thank you
to Jeff on shoots Jeff on shoots is the
first website member of the evening and
we will see we should see this pop right
up here there it goes so we are now one
of 15 to opening the phone lines and one
of 30 to guaranteeing another stream
this week as I mentioned before that
we've got only a few streams left in
2019 because we will be going on a show
vacation people asking how to become
members you go to join pakman.com the
infos right there you just read it I
want to say thanks also to eff fold
gently for signing up with twitch Prime
and people I see some people saying the
coupon code is not working I assure you
that it is I will actually show you
exactly how it works you do monthly or
yearly
I recommend yearly it's even cheaper but
you could do either you hit sign up you
type in last 2019 website mistyped it
last 20 1960 becomes $20.19 beautiful
beautiful if you want to do monthly you
can if you type that code in last 2019
that will make it two dollars in two
cents a month very very exciting stuff
speaking of which before we go on to the
next segment let's actually look at some
of the voicemails that are coming in
because there are some funny ones one is
there's a guy named he won't named he
goes by the name total control 871 and
he got very angry with me during a live
call last week where he asserted that
the me to movement went too far and
that's why Democratic women are losing I
asked him for examples he didn't have
any okay he's continued to leave
voicemails let's listen to a couple yo
pen one all right so check it out I just
got finished watching
kolinsky latest whistleblowing video on
YouTube is [ __ ] algorithm how they
suppress basically independent journals
like that yes who both they're what they
are like us I didn't know total control
871 was an independent journalist but
okay a fourth Edith on news content
basically
corporate media with a bunch of [ __ ]
money um let me ask you something
when was the last time you bought
antibacterial hand so I don't use
antibacterial hand soap if you think
that not too long ago it was all the
rage
basically antibacterial everything okay
all the morning shows such as our
corporate media was pushing this stuff
constantly yeah all right so anyway I'm
we're not gonna this is a three-minute
voicemail we're not going to listen to
it seems to be going into hand soap and
other health home and beauty care
products and then total control called
again this guy is sort of like the new
Jimmy from Philly in a way let's take
that one yo man I'm surprised you
haven't talked about the UM cloaked
subscriber scandal that's kind of
unfolding with YouTube's new guidelines
or whatever um so my channel has ground
to a halt
of eleven thousand eight hundred
subscribers how ok yeah people in the
chat are not thrilled with with what
total control is telling us so we'll
move on but anyway that's what's going
on there Thank You Tube roba FET prime
for subscribing with twitch prime that
cookie has sent another super chat
saying do you think that Trump if
elected in 2020 will attempt to
manipulate the system in order to run
for a third term he's joked about it
before I know he's joked about it I
actually do think he's just trying to
trigger us what was his name
Mike Huckabee in fact I can probably
pull up the tweet Mike Huckabee teased
going on Fox News and talking about that
as well let me see if I can find it here
governor Mike Huckabee but let's see
where it was this was last week December
14 I think it's got to be close to here
and I think it's just trolling and a lot
of people fell for it and I
decided not to cover it on my show okay
he's posting fight videos that's weird
okay here it is I'll be on Sean Hannity
tonight on Fox News at 9:00 p.m. and
will explain how Trump will be eligible
for a third term due to the illegal
attempts by Comey Dems and media trying
to oust him as POTUS so that's why I was
named to head up the 2024 election we
shouldn't even take the bait I mean I
think he's just trolling people and I
don't think I I don't think um I don't
think it's gonna happen and I don't
think I think Trump will assert that
everything's unfair he was he unfairly
lost and all of this stuff but I don't I
don't think that I don't think it's
really gonna be a serious thing Jason
Ealing popping up with a - British Pound
super chat I will be spending British
pounds soon I'm going to London soon
Jason Ealing says big fan of the channel
also want to say thanks to a luring Lord
who has subscribed for three months in a
row with twitch prime who says hey David
mostly good analysis on UK election
results on tonight's show although you
said Jeremy Corbyn resigned it's not
true he will early next year yes I did
mistakenly say that he has resigned he
will resign but I appreciate I got a lot
of positive feedback actually about the
analysis of UK politics we won't talk
about it now since it's on today's show
and the clips will be publishing very
very soon
let me say thanks to a few other new
members Rubin gazer has signed up at
join pakman.com Julia Beck has signed up
at join pakman.com
Thomas Smith has signed up at join
pakman.com and Brendon Galvan signed up
at join pakman.com that is four more
that gets us to five and there it goes
look at that stream we are moving right
ahead towards opening the phone lines I
also am seeing owed so let's let me ask
you folks about this Jeff Anschutz who
was the first person who signed up
during the stream has now upgraded his
membership so he's paid a second time
should I count that as the sixth new
member of the evening it's the same
person but he has upgraded his
membership
to 24 bucks a month which is very
generous should that count towards 6 on
Twitch most people seem to say yes on
YouTube
Wow YouTube is more split YouTube is uh
okay no yam everybody everybody's saying
yes alright so we will count it that
actually now gets us to 6 so if folks
want the phones open we are only 9 new
members away which is extremely
extremely exciting alright let's
continue with some of the other
voicemails just to see who's been
calling in let's see so I've not
pre-screened these so let's see we've
got country code 21 anytime I see that
that code is madman
I'm from Libya you know and I am I want
to ask you you know who who will win in
and democratic democratic election you
know well I don't know that I mean
that's that's a big thing they called
right back as well hi David Pakman my
name is Aslam Abdul Karim I am you know
I am I want to say something about about
I'm I am on a ask question but who will
win the Democratic okay so it seems to
be the same voicemail twice but with the
slightly different cadence I don't know
I think that the the obvious contenders
are Biden Warren and Bernie and Pete
Budaj edge you know he's all about
surging and and we'll see if he can do
it let's check out a couple other
voicemails I do it my name is David from
Philadelphia PA I just had a question
about the impeachment trial in the
Senate I understand that the lead
justice
Chief Justice resides as a judge in the
Senate trial mm-hmm he I know his role
is typically a ceremonial and there
preserve sort of due process even though
it's sort of more or less a political
trial does he is there a past precedent
for him to assert
neutrality on the Senators in the Senate
no there's this thing called the
Constitution which says that senators
regardless of party are supposed to just
be unbiased jurors effectively during
the Senate trial but there is no way
that there's no way that junk that John
Roberts could impose or demand or
enforce I guess neutrality and in fact
many Republican senators have already
said that they're not going to vote to
convict
so there's no question that they can't
do that
let's see Pamela says the front page
should have a membership button there's
a second button on the front page that
was how I signed up the front page does
have a woops the front page does have a
membership button as far as I know let's
see if you go to david pakman.com the
website I think is getting hammered
right now cuz a bunch of people are
signing up but I'll do my best to so oh
so I'm logged in so it doesn't show it
to me because I am a member I believe
that when you're not a member right here
there's a red button and it lets you
sign up okay
let's go to our next clip I'll go back
to I'll go back to voicemails
potentially but let me go back to the
let me go back to the next clip so this
is a clip where Brian Kilmeade from Fox
& Friends
says he's stunned by a Fox News poll
that says half the country wants Trump
impeached and removed let's take a
listen to the always insightful and
brilliant obviously I'm kidding Brian
Kilmeade
and by the way Steve Doocy and Ainsley
Earhardt
I'm having a hard time getting a read on
what their expressions are supposed to
communicate while Brian Kilmeade says
this Fox poll came out and I was stunned
by this it says 50% of the country want
the president peached
I was stunned to see that that's the
number because I thought things were
trending away
although the president's approval rating
did take up in the same poll so it's
almost like a split personality
meanwhile it's six minutes after the Box
man is kill me dumber than Greg Gutfeld
some people are asking in the chat yeah
I don't know we listen this is what
happens when you're in an a coach
which is you are surprised that half the
country wants this guy removed it is a
sort of race to the bottom for sure so
we're going to talk more I don't want to
like pre do my analysis for tomorrow
because there actually there's actually
a lot to discuss here even though it's
just Brian Kilmeade kind of being Brian
Kilmeade there's a lot to talk about so
we are going to what we'll save that for
tomorrow I've got a super chat in
Spanish from Jared Johnson coming in
with 20 Mexican pesos who says they who
stuck who do it at but a 50 guy I'm
guessing that that's a band of some kind
I've never heard of it
so I couldn't say for sure and then he
says Tomomi spaces have my pesos Thank
You Jared I appreciate it I wonder if
jared is an expat living in Mexico or
what what the story is with that I also
want to say thanks to fellow var for
subscribing with twitch Prime and SATA
dragon for subscribing for 3 months with
twitch prime alright let's go on to the
next story this is a really big story ok
and and I see people asking me when the
numbers are going to go up there that
they signed up I will get to that I want
to dig into this story
so listen from the start of the
impeachment hearings trumpets people
around Trump Giuliani that that
Republican lawyer Steve castor-oil as I
call him or Steve caster they have been
asserting that Trump and people around
around him weren't trying to get any of
the people working over in Ukraine out
of the way they had no idea of moving
Murray Ivanovich out of the way because
they found her to be problematic they've
been arguing that no no we were fine and
we were all about looking for corruption
and whatever else and then it turns out
that Rudy Giuliani told Adam entus in
this room this is a really good piece in
The New Yorker
this is from the upcoming issue but the
interview with Rudy was actually done
last month and I want to find the exact
part of this here where Rudy just admits
to the entire thing let me find the
exact spot here it is in a long
conversation with me this past November
Giuliani largely confirmed Lutz anko's
account of their relationship he too saw
you Jovanovic as an obstacle hindering
his attempt to dig up dirt against his
clients rival in advance of the 2020
election I believed that I needed
Jovanovic out of the way she was going
to make the investigations difficult for
everybody this is again saying the quiet
part outloud goes on to say Giuliani
compiled a dossier on the Biden's and
Jovanovic I'm actually I'm watching the
last latest season of the blacklist with
James Spader and yesterday in the
episode I watched yesterday he talks
about a dossier but I like how he pretty
pronounces it dossier there's a dossier
which was compiled by Giuliani on the
Biden's in Jovanovic which he sent to
Secretary of State Pompeo which was
shared with the FBI and with me John
Solomon a journalist had interviewed
Lysenko for the hill
Giuliani promoted the project I said
John let's make this as prominent as
possible I'll go on TV you go on TV you
do column so this is the key line I
believed that I needed you Voinovich out
of the way she was going to make the
investigations difficult they spent what
must have been 30 hours in impeachment
hearing testimony in the Intel committee
and later in the Judiciary Committee
arguing we had no grievance against
Jovanovic we were not targeting her we
were you know so on and so forth and
then Rudy just says it out loud that oh
yeah no we I needed her out of the way
for sure we needed to get her out of the
way this reminds me of aside from being
obstruction as people in the chatter
pointing out this reminds me of I know
it's hard to remember at this point but
remember when they would constantly say
contact with Russians we've never had
any contact with Russians Trump said
there was never contact with Russians
Jeff Sessions too
before it turned out that was a line he
recused himself and you know who else
pen said there was no contact with
Russians all this stuff and then all of
a sudden Don jr. tweets out oh yeah yeah
yeah no we had contact with Russians and
it was fine it's just there's nothing
illegal about it and then the goalposts
move happened to contact with with
Russians is not a problem whatsoever
this is the exact same that's happened
thing that's happening now it's more
boneheaded in the sense that it's more
like when the Trump administration was
not admitting that Trump had been
involved in any kind of payoff of stormy
Daniels and they denied it and they
denied it and they denied it and then
all of a sudden Rudy Giuliani goes on I
think it was Fox News and said oh yeah
yeah yeah no we paid I mean but it's
totally fine I mean this is just a you
know it's all illegal it's all perfectly
and completely fine
it's Giuliani yet again admitting it and
we'll have more coverage of this
tomorrow my intention was just to
preview this story today a self-aware
creative name says is the full jancuga
interview not yet available to members
you know the reason that it's not is we
only use part of it on today's broadcast
show and that's what's now available to
members part two is on tomorrow's show
so the full gen Kyogre interview today
where we talk about the endorsements
from Bernie we talked about this the
smear campaign we talked about
everything it's going to be publishing
late tonight on the YouTube channel and
it is very very interesting and I look
forward to hearing from people about it
let me say thanks to a couple of other
new members Elizabeth
Talley is a new member at join
pakman.com Paul Schultz is also a new
member at join pakman.com so that's that
now gets us more than halfway to opening
up the phone lines we are up to 8 of 15
new members and this is just like a
stretch goal if we were to get to 30
tonight I would I will definitely do
another stream this week otherwise I may
or I may not there's there's uh this is
our
week before vacation and we've got a lot
of extra stuff to film and I may or may
not stream but if we get the 30 I'll do
another stream for sure this week okay
let's get to some videos I have not
watched these videos yet but a few
people flagged them for me and and the
comment that was most frequently
included with these videos was hey David
do you have any idea any idea what
Donald Trump is talking about here so
let's listen to these together I haven't
listened to these yet because we're
going to keep our family farms and we're
going to get to keep South Dakota
wonderful and so I appreciate you're
gonna have a very exciting 4th of July
fireworks and fireworks I always found
that accent interesting that they have
up there many years for many years at
least 10 years ago nobody knows why but
you just couldn't have it and now you're
gonna have fireworks and I'm guessing
someone must know why if that's true
they stopped doing fireworks there the
governor called and she said you got to
do me a favor right and we worked it out
and we got it done and you're gonna have
fireworks and I appreciate what you said
in the trade deals they're incredible
deals and then big and they're big and
every once in a while you hear a critic
there has never been deals like this man
is Mike Pence's wife in the room cuz
he's not allowed to be with with women
unsupervised some globalist you know
they want us to lose money sometimes you
have a global is good and I watch it who
cares about the United States less lose
money I'm the opposite when I had
deficits I don't like deficits you have
some people that don't mind deficits and
deficits I don't like factories closing
implants Trump has exploded the deficit
it's like what is even talking opposing
in this country going to another country
taking our jobs so I've never really
been one to want to put up with it even
I've been watching it it's probably one
of the reasons I'm president I've
watched that for so many years we what
is he what is he talking about he's
watched what your factories and your
plants all over whether it's Indiana or
any other state
even you Asia right every once in a
while they're close one over
but it was the fact is I would watch as
they close plants
everybody gets fired they moved to
Mexico or some other place including
China and it just I don't move they just
buy the product and some people are
happy but no not me we keep our jobs
they're moving back the agreements very
tough the USMC is very very tough it's
very hard to move economic all right so
I mean it's not making a lot of sense
but I see that he's trying to say
everything's great let's listen to this
next one here let's see which one gets
gets really bad what mr. president how
much was Giuliani shared with you about
his recent trip to Ukraine he was 50
years he was the best mayor in the
history of the city of New York
he's our country and he does this he
does it out of love
he sees what goes on you sees what's
happening he sees all of the hoax that
happens when they talk about impeachment
hoax or the Russian collusion delusion
yeah Giuliani is an expert on hoaxes all
right and then let's go more oh no this
is the same one oh okay so yeah I mean
listen he's not making a lot of sense
but it's not the most unhinged that I've
seen from be I mean it's just it's just
the normal sighting of fraudulent
talking points and that that's basically
it let me say thanks to Roger Martin
Roger Martin has signed up at join
pakman.com that gets us to nine if we
get only six more new members look at
that blue bar just rocketing across the
screen if we get just six more new
members we will open up the phone lines
super chat has come in and if you buy of
course by the way if you're watching on
YouTube please if you have any questions
or comments for me send them in via
super chat and I will
new Veljko says the bernie warren guy
stuff is weird
this is a reference to me saying I'm I'm
in the Bernie Warren camp of the
Democratic primary makes it seem like
there's too little difference between
them for even leftist commentators to
distinguish them oh come on give me a
break I have done stories about here are
the important differences between Bernie
and Warren and we've talked about that
there are differences between all of the
candidates but for the purposes of
talking about the contingent that the
establishment is trying to deny the
nomination to it is both Bernie and
Warren for slightly different reasons
two slightly different degrees but they
both represent a threat to the financial
elite status quo and I'm not saying they
are the same but they are certainly in
the same wing of the primary and I think
it's a completely reasonable thing for
me to be saying in order to point out
when I say that it's not about finding
the differences it's about talking about
the coalition and I you know as folks
are pointing out these purity tests it's
old I don't participate in it period is
basically the the gist of it okay let me
play a couple more voicemails and then
I'll thank some you oh I I do want to
thank a few people over on Twitch thank
you to Joe Heyman 54 for subscribing for
the second month with twitch prime
I very much appreciate that and also
thanks to I got karma to collect for
cheering one hundred bits let's listen
to a couple of other voicemail see
what's on folks mate
David this is Freddy Venetta I watched
your show I was a very proud Democrat
many years ago I'm growing up and I've
learned to become I guess maybe more
center-right and that's just because of
I guess I'm sure all the topics we
talked about on your show and I've seen
all of your debates I think they're all
very interesting one thing that I've
always wanted to get from you or from
people on the left
it's like what is the idea or this
utopia of what then is the I the perfect
world that we should live in if it is
that the left views are the correct news
whether from the tax rate to the social
programs that are available any kind of
entitlements like what is the correct
amount so that way I can understand
truly why the left would be the correct
ideology if any you know the more more
listen I can tell you what the policies
should be but that won't tell you that
they are correct yeah so people have
asked me what should the top tax rate be
it's not my opinion it's we have a lot
of good academic research that says the
top marginal tax rate and you've got to
understand what that means of course the
top marginal tax rate should be right
around 70% and it should be a much
higher bracket right now our highest
bracket only goes to I think about
$500,000 there should be much higher
brackets where you would get you know a
50 55 60 and at some point I don't know
if it's a 10 million dollar a year
income or where it is you pay a marginal
tax rate of about 70 percent that that's
what I think you know you have I see
some people in the chat saying no
billionaires should be taxed at a
hundred percent
I've not seen academic research from the
field of economics that says that that's
a good idea what I see as the best idea
is that you top out between seventy and
seventy three percent and it's at a
higher income we need more brackets and
they need to go up when it comes to
health care I think I mean listen people
know what I think about health care we
should make sure everybody has health
care regardless of ability to pay
it's economically stimulative it's a
good thing in so many different ways
healthy people work a you know I think
we understand that so I'm not gonna go
through through every policy but if
you're in good faith asking about that
there is more than enough material on
record on my youtube-channel for folks
to suss it out Nouvel coast comes back
with another
super chat saying so then when's the
endorsement choose already once again
I've already said I am NOT going to do
anything that may fuel the circular
firing squad purity test in fighting
wing of the left so I have been very
clear I will tell you who I altom utley
vote for the primary what is one is in
2020 Democratic primary Massachusetts
date in Massachusetts we vote on March
3rd and I think that by then we will
have a lot more information about who is
viable and who is not and I will be
voting for either Bernie or Warren and I
will tell you who and I don't think my
votes gonna make a difference because my
sense is that in Massachusetts it's not
going to be a closed primary but we will
certainly tell you who I ultimately vote
for let's see let's check out a couple
of other voicemails that have come in
hey David
my name is Paul and I'm gonna regular
listen to you listener to your show
actually I watched on YouTube but I
really enjoy it
one of the things we talked about in
fact that YouTube is because bit of a
pain in the butt well today I saw a
video from a YouTube channel called
Menace lineThe tech tips Linus oh my god
I got a bailout I can't just can't hear
a word that's being said incredible TV
comes in via super chat says David have
you heard about clown New Jersey rep
Jeff van drew switching to the
Republican Party because of impeachment
what are your thoughts on it if Trump
wins America loses wake up folks yeah I
did see that and it's just it's it's
pretty it I I just don't even have much
I want to say about it it's just a clown
and I don't I don't care about him and
he should just go away I have a hard
time you know we have so many other
important things to talk about that
I don't want to let this one guy take up
too much space in my mind I see dead
llamas sends a ten-dollar super chat non
sequitur in my home state of North
Dakota a lot passed that allowed only
three refugees into the state thankfully
towns are fighting it but do you think
North Dakota being the first domino in
anti-refugee laws it may be so there's a
there's sort of like some new there's
new frontiers new battle lines along a
lot of these issues so for example when
gay marriage nationally was legalized by
the Supreme Court effectively legalized
back in 2015 we knew that the new battle
lines would be along religious freedom
arguments along employment
discrimination and that's exactly where
it has been we are starting to see
state-level
battle lines being drawn when it comes
to refugees and I hope that it's not the
first domino but they you know I think
that what happens in 2020 will certainly
be a factor in figuring that out let me
say thank you to Braille earth Ramirez
Braille earth Ramirez is new member
number 10 of the evening thanks so much
brailers I appreciate that five new
members and I will open up the phone
lines my suggestion is let's just do it
let's just do it and get the phone lines
open so we can talk to as many folks as
possible remember that we have a
fantastic coupon code at join pakman.com
that coupon code is last 2019 it works
on both monthly and yearly memberships
just do it and get it done for the year
you'll be good until December 16th of
2020 if you sign up today with this
coupon code last 2019 you'll pay just
$20.19 which is a steal by the way but
then you'll be good until beyond the
election it you imagine your membership
renewal date won't even come up until
after Donald Trump has hopefully
although probably not I'm realistic not
been reelected is is my hope and my goal
but we will see ultimately if that
happens people asking if I will take
phone lines from twitch if they if the
if I take what will take phone calls
from twitch of course I have no all I
see is phone numbers I don't know when I
see the number if it's somebody from
twitch or from YouTube a couple of other
super chats here
negan the cliffhanger says Dave how long
is your goob Asst I have no idea what
that means but I can guess Eileen Burke
also comes in with a dollar super check
thank you so much
Timo s says as a queer first-generation
Mexican have to be a Bernie Warren guy I
don't know what that means Timo but I
very very much appreciate it it looks
like the yang Yang is more represented
on twitch today than it is on YouTube is
that is that possible or do I have that
wrong just I'm just seeing a lot more
yang propagandizing over on twitch just
for kicks I haven't looked at polling I
don't know if there's any new polling
from over the weekend how is Andrew yang
doing let's just take a look what new
polling do we have so we've got one okay
I guess this was released today and yang
is polling three okay so I mean that's
similar to where he's been in this poll
we've got Biden 30 Warren 17 Bernie 16
effectively a statistical tie Abood edge
edge at nine and Michael Bloomberg at
seven Wow
I mean it is truly stunning the amount
of support that Mike Bloomberg has been
able to buy there's no question about
that
I'm actually curious whether Bloomberg
is going to end up getting himself into
debates remember Bloomberg is not
accepting individual donations and there
was a donor requirement in order to get
into the debates so as of now no matter
what he polls he can't get into the
debates and there is speculation light
speculation I would call it sort of like
light treason there's light speculation
that he will that the rules will be
changed in order to allow him into the
debates which would be absolutely
incredible
let's see we've got a couple more new at
least one more new member
Fahd lee Johari oddly Johari is new
member number eleven of the evening
thanks so much fondly i appreciate that
and that that gets us to eleven and just
for new members away from opening up the
phone lines other super chats that i did
want to address thanks awesome gaming
for the super chat appreciate that team
OS says Bernie Warren are the only
candidates fighting for my rights
all right Timo I appreciate that that
you feel that way
and Eileen Burke also came in with a
super chat but has retracted her message
I'm always curious about those
retractions what what was there how does
that even work
I don't really know let's listen to a
couple of other voicemails here which
one did I leave off at didn't we already
listen to this one David oh yeah this
was the the one that was breaking up
David now are you a huge fan here so I'm
a little confused here you know concern
about Trump winning in 2020 now my
understanding the way I see I don't see
how that's possible if you think in
terms of you know the process of a
process of addition right so obviously
you have the trumps there's the
dialogues they're not going anywhere
Trump could shoot someone at Fifth
Avenue as he says right absolutely no
matter what you have those but don't you
have to gain voters like just me
personally just an informal poll I've
not met one person who said Oh
Trump's doing a great job I voted for
Hillary in 16 and you know what I'm
gonna vote for named 2020 so it's just
I'm confused can you help me out with
the math all right Thank You Love You
chef so here's the thing there's two
there's two elements here that we need
to understand number one half the
country doesn't vote okay half when half
the country doesn't vote you can't just
say oh here's what we had in 2016
clearly some people are disaffected that
means Trump wins
half the country doesn't vote so then it
comes down to who is actually motivated
to get out and vote so as an example
imagine that you have disaffected
Trumpets who were planning on not voting
and then Trump gets impeached and
acquitted in the Senate and Trump
successfully says witch-hunt they went
after all this stuff now you have
invigorated Trump voters you've not
necessarily changed anyone's mind about
I'd rather Trump over a Democrat what
you've changed is whether they're going
to get out and vote or not early in
trump's presidency there was a ton of
catalyzed and coalesced activism from
the left the rallies the women's march
and so on some of that I feel has waned
and so obviously any of those people if
if they vote in November of 2020 would
vote against Donald Trump but are they
going to vote so that's why and then of
course number two that we have an
electoral college system so you can
actually lose the popular vote you get
this would be unlikely to happen but you
can lose the popular vote by more than
ten points or even more and still win
the electoral college it's quite a crazy
system that we have Macola 99 says via
super chat have you seen Trump sounds
like Jim Jones part three no I don't
know what that is let me look for it
Trump sounds like Jim Jones part three
I'm not finding anything with that name
unfortunately but it sounds interesting
I recently read a book about Jim Jones
and I very much very much enjoyed it as
disgusting as it was a thanks to Dale
summons Dale summons has signed up at
join pakman.com and Dale is the 12th new
member of the evening look at that I
just love the new graphics we are only
three members away from opening the
phone lines people saying David what's
better about phone lines than voicemails
well when you I don't know how many
people here are familiar with phone
calls but during phone calls both people
can talk in real time as opposed to me
just reacting to what people said by a
voicemail let's listen to just a couple
more
hi David it's an American number but on
the other side is a German Bavarian guy
my name is Heinz from Munich list I'm 66
already living in the States from 84 to
86 okay serving for the NATO in the time
of Ronald Reagan II especially for the
Secretary of Air Force I know your
country quite well I love your country
I am completely disturbed about the
proceedings in your country now I always
thought that the humanistic core does
your country so this goes on so for four
minutes so maybe I'll listen to the rest
of it offline it seems more appropriate
for sort of you know cozying up with a
scotch next to a fire and listening to
then maybe on stream let's listen to
what I watch your show I I just want her
to give you congratulate in when you
show amazing and I think that you are
very talented and I just absolutely love
to watch you in - listen tear tear to
your eye to the stuff thank you I really
appreciate I appreciate you checking out
all of my students will that that our
display 46:30 true I'd say the main in
doing a great job the Democrat me the
gurgi allow the mayor oh they get more
money they they got in the prison
president that we got just trying to
maintain people thank you I don't know
if that was for or
against Donald Trump but I do appreciate
the message for sure let's let's try
just one more of these
hey David something that I've been
wondering about for a long time well at
least for the last two years is there
what would be involved in and is there
ever a possibility that you can foresee
that there would be an amendment added
to the Constitution so that for
presidential candidate requirements
right now there's just the two and one
of them seems kind of a little
ridiculous but that being the age
specifically but the question all right
so it looks like they've lost their
train of thought right this is why we
pre-screen voicemails that go on the
that go on the show a couple other super
chats young dumb and baroque says if
Schumer Pelosi coordinates so that the
house with holds voting on articles
until a fair trial is set wouldn't Mick
turtle go oh well no impeachment you
know even Mitch McConnell seems to
understand that in the case of
impeachment it's not up to him whether
or not to do the trial he you know
McConnell is one of the biggest obstruct
errs that we've seen and he often sort
of governs by obstruction which is
simply you know you control the the
Senate and you just don't bring things
up that would be disadvantageous I
actually heard him say I have no choice
in the matter if the house files
articles of impeachment we have to have
a trial now he said he would coordinate
with Trump on the trial but no I don't
think that m'q turtle as you refer to
him would have that possibility
honey dog honey dog says is it racist
when conservatives complain about
entitlements or maybe maybe they mean it
does it sound racist when conservatives
complain about entitlements sometimes it
does sometimes it doesn't it depends on
the particular case but very often there
is a racial element in talking about how
you want to shrink government and get
rid
of entitlements Matthew good tell says
via super chat what are your thoughts
about Democrats being blamed like always
for the eminent recession
listen there's the political answer and
then there's the economic answer so the
political answer is basically BS and you
know I could say whatever and say
something super partisan the reality is
that economies move it relatively slowly
except when you have something acute
that happens like a 9/11 for example
and/or you know you start a war or
something like that when Barack Obama
was running for re-election against Mitt
Romney I said it then I said no matter
who wins the economy will probably be
pretty good now there are some things
regardless for the next four years there
are some things that Mitt Romney could
do that might change the trajectory
there are things Obama could do but
basically the economy was likely to
remain pretty good and then towards the
end of Barack Obama's presidency I
started saying listen we're terrible at
predicting when there's going to be a
recession but what we know is that we're
one day closer to the next one today and
we are going to be another day closer
tomorrow we don't know exactly when it
will be but it is starting to have been
the amount of time since the last one
where we would start to think one may be
upcoming and I think that that is likely
so I think that that is likely to happen
regardless of who is president
eventually the president could change
the trajectory create an inflection
point so I I would love it if the
economic discussions that we have could
be more less political so to speak
because there there is a lot that's
political in the economy and there's
also a lot that is cyclical there are
factors beyond the control of the person
in the White House that doesn't make for
good clips on YouTube right because
everybody's supposed to be hyper
partisan and and it's that those aren't
great discussions Adam D says via super
chat hey David you mentioned that half
of the country doesn't get to vote I'm
just curious on why that is no I didn't
say half the country doesn't get to vote
half the country chooses
to vote after the country chooses not to
vote and there's also suppression that
prevents some people from voting Adam D
clarifying I'm Canadian though that's
fine Canadian super chats are completely
and totally allowed on this program
thanks so much to any Greenfield for
subscribing for the fourth month in a
row with twitch Prime I appreciate that
and also thanks to new member Jason gray
Jason gray is a new member number 13 of
the evening that gets us to just within
two of opening up the phone lines this
is going to be a tight one I was
thinking of the cutoff for taking phone
calls being 7:45 and p.m. Eastern Time
and we're just seven minutes from that
so I think if people want the phone
lines open my recommendation is to get a
quick membership over at join pakman.com
and then we'll open up the phone lines
let's see other questions and comments
that I have missed so far Oh Keith Stone
says hate Trump but Democrats are worse
can those people be flipped I mean yes
they can but it's not really worth the
time it takes so I've said this before
you know you skilled rhetorician z' can
argue with trumpets with varying degrees
of success and sometimes get them to
change their mind but because half the
country doesn't vote the effort that's
required to get one trumpets to change
their mind is far more than what it
would take to just get five people who
already agree with you to understand the
importance of voting and so yes they
that their minds can be changed but the
question is that what what time cost
that what investment of time and I don't
think that it is a strategy for winning
an election let me put it that way
I see dead llamas says via super chat
her Dewan threatened to acknowledge the
genocide
Native Americans a concept that many are
already aware of but my question is do
you think the US government will
acknowledge it or at least strip Wounded
Knee
M Oh Medal of Honor z' I have no idea
you know that's not an issue that I've
followed closely so I wouldn't be able
to say I wish I had a better answer but
I just don't know enough about it and I
don't want to you know I think it's okay
I'd rather people say when they don't
know rather than make up some BS answer
and I just don't know the answer to that
Sammy
Ali Aragon says do Republicans have the
ability to hack and change votes on
machines why are they blocking all
attempts to secure elections nobody's
talking about it I've been talking about
it so your question do Republicans have
the ability to hack and change votes on
machines the manufact that can be done
on the machines I'm trying to figure out
the right way to say this that can
certainly be done on the machines the
question is do Republicans have the
wherewithal and resources to make that
happen
and I don't know the answer I think it's
certainly plausible and the reason
they're blocking all attempts to secure
elections is that they know election
interference helps them they know that
voter suppression helps them why would
you I mean they don't see it as anything
to be fixed that this is a glue this is
a feature this is how they're going to
win welcome to Elzbieta Marciniak
Elzbieta Mars ENIAC is new member number
14 of the evening which gets us just one
member shy of opening the phone lines
and my sense is that we may actually
hear both from folks over on twitch and
YouTube if the phone lines are open we
are just one new member away so if folks
want the phone lines to open you know
what to do you know what to do for for
sure Madeline Welsh says do you think
canvassing door to door for candidates
is helpful yeah so listen at the
presidential level given internet media
social media etc I actually don't know
that canvassing door to door is predict
useful particularly when a lot of times
you know some portion of the people
aren't home some other percentage don't
talk to people that knock on the door it
seems as though those resources could
better be deployed elsewhere now in
local elections in congressional
elections I interviewed Genki ogor today
and he said he's going and knocking on
doors and that is something that when
you're you know when the entire
electorate is seven hundred and
something thousand people like in a
congressional district when you're
talking about City Council mayoral etc
of course of course you go and you you
can visit for presidential elections I
really am unsure I really am just not I
just don't know the math of it and the
resources can be deployed in other ways
I just don't know
thanks to salt okra C for subscribing
for three months in a row on Twitch
prime with the message it's an easy
thing to fix
take the voting machines offline and
make the input selection on them very
limited yeah we've um we've talked about
the way to secure our elections and
there does not seem to be a willingness
to do it over on YouTube via super chat
Michael Blanco says hey David you think
it would be more damaging for Trump to
participate in the general debates than
sitting them out afraid he would get
humiliated no because listen he lost
every he law but bite by all standard
measures Trump lost the debates against
Hillary Clinton but it didn't matter
because they have narrative they have
fox news I don't think that Trump I
think short of you know a physical
attack on the opponent which I they
would probably say with self-defense
anyway I think that they can basically
defend any outcome that Donald Trump has
during the election debates the general
election debates and I don't think that
there I don't think there's much of a
risk either way that's the really scary
thing I think either way they are able
able to defend what what happens and
claim that it was either
what Trump had to do or a reaction to
what somebody else did or a fake news
story or whatever the case may be
welcome to Damon wells and someone who
is going by the name open phones please
that is two new members that gets us to
16 and let's open the phone lines let's
do it as promised the phone number will
be 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I promised I would
do it so I will do it let me get myself
a new version of Skype is installing a
lot of things getting a little bit
hectic over here and remember if we do
get to 30 new members I will guarantee
another stream later on this week so
let's see what's on people's minds at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let me get myself
connected to the system first thank you
for calling in to the David Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and listen for David to
call out your area code very good advice
alright 6 1 7 8 3 0 47:58 3 0 47 50 that
is ok let's get right on with oh let's
go to Oz from the 5 3 0 oz last time Oz
was on he actually had a little bit of
sad news for us but hopefully hopefully
it's good news from odds today what's
going on hey Dave
how's it going good how are you good so
I'm in Cincinnati now and this was a
local story but it made national
headlines and it really upset me and
it's about a local judge and she was
appointed by Bevin the former governor
yeah and so she she got busted having
group sex and partying and drinking and
doing crazy stuff it on the clock in the
courthouse inner chambers while she was
you know between sentencing people to
poor people to harsh punishments that
are ruining their lives and
so and this is all in the news you can
look it up her name is gantry justice
gantry and she hasn't even stepped down
and it said to me that just shows the
extreme systemic corruption of the
entire system it's just uh it's just a
microcosm into the macrocosm
yeah I'm pulling it up right now let's
Dodge country faces allegations of
giving favoritism in exchange for sex
and money a family court judge is under
investigation after being accused of
having a threesome at work and asking a
colleague to have group sex with her and
a former pastor wow I wonder what the
nomination that pastor is this is an
introduced a crazy story oz yeah well
and there's been a quite a few other
things that have been in the local news
of similar subject including a local guy
on the he was on the the Human Rights
Commission the firt of the city of
Covington the same city and he got
busted with child porn Wow
ran this this was recently too and then
there's there's been all kinds of weird
stuff look I mean we got the the
Covington cast school close by that's uh
you know remember the the incident with
the the Covington ADA's I and the drama
yeah and then some of those same kids
have now have rape charges against them
that's been that's been in the news too
is that true that's in just money
because oh yeah
I don't know if it's I'm not saying the
same kids that were on that film but the
same school like this I'm hoarse click
but uh well this area has a lot of
Vatican influence once you go a little
further south it's more of an Jellicle
Baptist with the Cincinnati coming
Northern Kentucky Indiana tri-state area
it's right it's kind of interesting
place but yes just I mean it just makes
me sick because I've been you know
through the system myself and I've done
time and I've seen you know for my
experiences I'm not making excuses for
what I did because I you know paid the
price but uh I mean I've had multiple
duis and I've had felony charges snotty
nothing like see it's all like nothing
that would get me in trouble
you know no no moral crimes of moral
turpitude type thing but
now Oz I'm curious if your if you're
open to telling me like what what goes
on when you end up with the DUI like is
it do you know you shouldn't be driving
but something just takes over
is it circumstance what happens what do
you mean what causes me to have the DUI
yeah like in other words something makes
you say I'm gonna get behind the wheel
even though I shouldn't right well I'm
blacked out at that point I have I'm not
in control at all
I salmon on autopilot I say I mean stuff
like that only happens when I'm by
myself drinking this I had I've had four
duis and I had to have a breathalyzer
for three years in my vehicle Wow the
step seven seventy bucks a month for
three years and are you doing okay how
are you doing now I'm doing better I've
went on I kind of go on binges there's
been times where I you know stay drunk
for days and there's times where I don't
drink for a couple weeks or a couple
months and then it's just a form of
self-medication because I'm I'm bipolar
but with uh mild psychotic features and
I have PTSD I was in the military plus I
was the ptsds from the incarceration but
and are you getting uh are you getting
the the treatment you need for for that
no not not really because it's really
it's this is a major problem that a lot
of people have is especially veterans
who are relying on VA health care if you
I mean I work eight two four eight two
five and so they closed it for 4:30 or
5:00 so it's it's almost impossible for
me to get to the to the see the
counselor there to the meeting so it's
not a financial thing it's not a
financial thing it's just a life is busy
thing well it's a financial thing
because if I had better health care I
could I'd have access to to doctors to
care when I when I need it afterwards
because I can't I mean I can ask off I
can ask to leave early but it just
creates problems when I do that I mean
oh right yeah and then that that's all
the time
I'm off here then not paid I mean the
adoption right well the option is I
could go to rehab but I don't it's more
of a impulsive thing it's like I don't I
mean I've gone through four detoxes
before but I mean I can stop and not
drink for a couple days I'm not going to
you know I'm not going to have a seizure
it's not that bad
I've had I've been close to that in the
past and different periods but but if I
were to go in to read that rehab I would
have to I would lose my job probably I
would probably lose my home right
because I would I mean it's like that
and that's a big problem for a lot of
people especially the underclass and so
but eventually I mean first for some
people who are more extreme with other
things that will catch up with them and
never we always so well we got to figure
it out that's also because when you're
when you get out there and when you and
you're driving and and you're
intoxicated you're putting other
people's lives at risk
oh absolutely but I don't I don't see
that ever happening again after all the
crap I've gone through with it I mean
there's a bird I mean I think things if
I know I'm good I mean I take
precautions these days it's just in the
day in the age of uber it's it's just
senseless
yeah absolutely all right hear from you
you know hope you keep yeah we want you
to do well here
thank you didn't kill himself all right
thank you very much I was God you had to
get that and so we will we now
demonetized because of that all right
Eileen Burke says do you fear the rise
of state-run media due to trumps attack
on the media and Fox News absolutely
Keith stone says what about Eric's wall
well for VP he killed it at the hearings
and looked sharp he did look very sharp
I think demographically he's unlikely to
be selected for better or worse new
Valco says I love the debates with Euron
Brooke are you happy with the outcome
happy enough yeah happy enough let's go
to our next caller from the 772 area
code who's calling today from 7-7 - hey
David it's Kenny I'm in Brooklyn first
of all I just wanted to say it like I
feel for the previous caller like do
your thing man
I continue improving but uh my question
for you David is uh so I would consider
myself a communist and like I don't know
exactly what the nomination because I'm
still reading through capital right now
but um I was just wondering why you uh
you like had this whole big to-do about
like trying to find a label for what you
now call the revolutionary left are the
yeah the revolutionary left I was
wondering why I don't just call them
Communists is usually that's the
denomination that they would fall in
there well here's why they're not all
communists and I don't think communists
not all not all of the revolutionary
left are necessarily communists and not
all communists necessarily have the
foreign policy ideas of the
revolutionary left I guess that's why so
what would be like a foreign policy
difference that you would say is
different between like the Communists
and a revolutionary leftist it really
depends on the issue I mean there's so
many ways to slice and dice this but
it's not there is not a guarantee that
someone who believes that the right way
that the u.s. that you know their
country should be organized that
comically is communism yet can you hear
me boy all right listen you could think
that your economy should be communistic
and believe it or not believe that man
that that is just very strange what's
going on
okay less that more in the future
let's go to the next caller from the
nine seven one area code who's calling
today from nine seven one that is a
bowling alley if I've ever heard one
before that's a straight up bowling it
sounds like you're bowling but it
literally that was literally bowling yes
that's you early are you at bowling
alley no no no I have my bluetooth on
and I was driving I'm parking no oh I
thought we finally had an apple here
caller from a bowling alley can you hear
me yes
again I'm so sorry can you hear me David
yes okay awesome this is Jason from
Portland and I was wondering has the
House voted on the articles of
impeachment already know they have it
okay I forgot my other question so thank
you for taking my call
very good in the future you can look
that up much quicker than waiting on
hold twelve minutes to talk to me but I
really do appreciate you calling it
anyway right oh okay wait wait wait uh
so what was a good source of reliable
news to look up because I just watch you
and I've heard you say before to look
look around on the internet and so
whenever I look I can't find anything
that's worthwhile I feel like there's
one source that is right all the time
what I say is get your news from a
variety of sources and develop over time
you know an assessment of whether they
are reporting facts or whether they are
opinion or whatever the case may be
that's my suggestion okay awesome thank
you okay thanks so much great to hear
from you Steve gee says via super chat
how can it be justified that Lindsey
Graham had so many bad things to say
about Trump years ago and is now
metaphorically embedded with them do
they have dirt on him or is it tribal BS
I don't know I think it could be either
I think it could be either or both I've
wondered about the Lindsey Graham thing
myself quite frankly I didn't Sandstrom
says hey David first time supporting do
you agree with Andrew yang that we
should be legal yes
psychedelics should be legal yes and
opioids should be decriminalized yes I
do and and I agree with other candidates
on that as well next caller from the 608
area code who is calling today from 608
caller from 608 it appears that you have
us muted maybe unmute 608
hello yes there you are you're now
unmuted thank you oh yeah sorry I got
little ones I just wanted to make sure
they weren't gonna make a bunch of noise
when you answered and think I wasn't
here so the question that I had for you
is what do you think about the idea of
being able to crowdfund instead of
depending on the government to help fix
the climate change crisis problems that
were are popping up all over the country
as well as what's been going on for in
Flint now for almost the better part of
a decade listen I'm not against it in
the sense that I think it's great when
people say here's something we want to
do and we want to come together and put
our money into this problem to fix it
the problem is it's sort of like you
know those stories where little Timmy in
third grade did did a bake sale to fund
his cancer treatment and everybody
contributed and now he has money for the
first week of cancer treatment and we
treat it like it's great and it's like
the problem is that little Jimmy needed
to fundraise for his cancer treatment in
the same way we shouldn't have
particularly when the science is so
clear on climate change
we shouldn't be in a situation where
somebody's got to run a GoFundMe and
it's such a massive issue that I don't
really know that it could be done via
crowdfunding but I have no problem with
it okay well I have one of my best
friends is a is a pretty huge activist
myself and him have been to Flint
largely off of donations we've gotten
from a GoFundMe he has called the
people's fund and it's it's a pretty
awesome feeling if anybody's you know
knows a neighborhood or a community
that's affected by you know either the
side effects of climate change or just
the negligence of the local governments
to be able to go there and see like a
complete stranger you know look into
your eyes like you know my babies can
not drink a deadly bottle tonight right
all right
well that's right work that you're doing
it I love it I just don't know that
we're going to solve the climate crisis
that way but I appreciate the phone call
all right well I just wanted to say I'm
a huge fan of yours I've been calling
for weeks and finally got through so oh
good my pleasure thank you so much
somebody posted something hilarious in
the YouTube chat David Pakman I
discovered your channel on YouTube today
by searching skinny YouTube nerd it's
like could that possibly be true if it's
if it's true it's amazing and if it's
not then very very well done let's go to
our caller from the three six zero area
code who's calling today from three six
zero hi my name is Brendan I'm from
Eastern Washington State I'm relatively
new to watching a show but a friend of
mine has recommended it for quite a
while he's more in tune with independent
media and news and politics and I am
terrific I had a couple yeah I had a
couple questions for you really quickly
I'm not big into politics because I
think it's kind of messy and a lot of
it's very toxic but I'm really big in a
philosophy that's what I study currently
um what texts would you recommend I read
regarding political theory first stuff
just to get a broad view of what what
you would consider the important stuff I
read some long but I haven't read much
more than that
there's just so mean that there's no way
I could do the question justice what
what I would actually do is because I
don't want it I don't want to pretend
that there could be any way to be
comprehensive I would actually get some
of the very short introductions you know
that series they're like these little
books it's a British publisher yeah I've
read a couple for a history class
perhaps yeah right so grab the one for
political science political theory grab
a few of them you don't even necessarily
need to buy them look in the
bibliography because those books are a
treasure trove of what are good source
materials to start reading and you'll
find stuff dating back way beyond Locke
and new
stuff as well fantastic I had one more
quick question yeah what do you think
the relationship between ethics and
political theory is or should be like
between someone's ethical values and
their political ideals that's what they
would like to vote for should they be
the same or should there should they
separate their ethical concerns when
they're talking about politics and how
to govern society as a whole
my sense is I don't know how you really
separate them and that at some point
sure pragmatism may modulate what you
choose to vote for from a practical
perspective but no I tend to think I
mean listen for I can speak for me
personally I don't know how I would
separate my ethics from my political
voting decisions and activism okay
thanks fantastic thank you very much
all right appreciate it very much I'm
seeing them that somebody's asking me do
i monkish gamer says do I not respond to
questions with twitch donations I I do
when I see them but I'm not I'm not
seeing any others that other other than
the ones that I've mentioned so I
apologize if I miss something
let's go to our caller from the
three-one-seven area code who's calling
today from 307 hey my name is Erin can
you hear me okay
yes I can hi okay um so I'm in Indiana
I've been listening to you now here for
a couple of months and I really enjoy I
watched over the weekend I watched your
you had a video on is the DNC trying to
split the vote to let super delicate
pick Biden do you remember that yes I do
yeah and super delegate actually this
year and was a delegate in 2016 and I
spoke with her about I thought your
video is interesting I spoke with her
about it and you know they can't vote
until the second round this time right
that there was that conspiracy theory
that you know the super-delegates are
you know they're trying to get them to
pick Biden